you're on a road trip the kind that
stretches over days on end and you need
to make multiple stops along the way to
refuel the car and yourself the last
time you remember stopping to get more
gas and a bite to eat was back in
wyoming and now you're in the heart of
montana thankfully like an oasis in the
desert you see the town of clearwater
off in the distance it's a vibrant
welcoming little place a perfect slice
of classic small town americana you took
a similar trip last year and vaguely
remembers stopping at clearwater that
time too and you're glad to be back in
particular you remember the old prairie
diner a folksy little place with the
most delicious huckleberry pie you ever
tasted perhaps it's about time for you
to give it another try you fill up your
tank and stop at the diner the food
tastes just as good as you remember but
one thing is off the entire staff seems
to have changed it is the exact same
diner you ate at a year ago no doubt
about that but it looks like everyone
from the wait staff to the cashier to
the cooks have all been replaced you try
your best not to think about it after
all businesses are allowed to replace
their staff but the longer you sit in
the diner the more uncomfortable the
feelings become you need to ask someone
just to push away the fears that you're
not going crazy when the waiter passes
by you compliment the food and mention
you ate here last year too you asked the
unfamiliar waiter if they had worked
here back then they confirmed that yes
they've always worked here and so has
everybody else the diner is a family
business you leave town not too long
after that feeling vaguely unsettled and
as a voice on the radio warns about the
incoming rain you tell yourself that you
never want to return to the town of
clearwater montana as you leave the
memory of the town seems to fade from
your mind in real time but little do you
know the people of clearwater will never
be able to leave ever it's because
something horrifying will happen in
clearwater every single year and that
thing is known to the scp foundation as
scp-3300 this annual anomalous event is
clearwater's own local curse always
occurring around mid-june while many of
the mechanics of this event still elude
the foundation's understanding the
outcome is well documented every single
inhabitant of the town is replaced by a
person who didn't previously exist while
some elements may carry over from their
original counterparts every person
involved will simply be a whole new
person with no memories of the change or
who they once were the process known as
scp-3300 lasts between 6 and 18 days and
once the process has begun it's
impossible for any outsiders to
intervene it begins with rain a light
greery drizzle at first but each day the
rain gets worse soon it's a storm and
then a mouse drum flooding hurricanes
tornadoes all centered around clear
water but cutting off neatly just beyond
it what happens in clearwater remains in
clearwater and when the process has
concluded and the sun shines once more
everybody has been changed whenever the
foundation has tried to send personnel
or equipment into clearwater during
scp-3300
one of two things has happened in the
more favorable scenarios those
attempting to enter clearwater have
simply appeared on the other side of the
city limits in the less positive
instances personnel and equipment have
been lost forever within there is no
stopping or even understanding scp-3300
according to foundation records
clearwater has been around at least as
long as the foundation itself perhaps
even longer clearwater has been able to
undergo its yearly nightmare without
intrusion due to a unique
cognito-hazardous effect which creates a
kind of mental block around memories of
the town for outsiders you won't forget
clearwater per se but you will find it
increasingly hard to focus on like
something you can only ever see out of
the corner of your eye there is no
saving the people of clearwater the
horror will play out again and again and
again the foundation has no first-hand
knowledge of what happens in clearwater
during those horrifying 18 days but one
account they have hints at a terrifying
possibility during an excursion into
clearwater the foundation managed to
collect a diary belonging to a woman
named margaret lane to the best of our
knowledge margaret lane no longer exists
but if the contents of her diary aren't
to be believed then what goes on in
clearwater during scp-3300
is far worse than we ever imagined
margaret first started her diary not
long before
scp-3300's 1995 iteration began she was
in the middle of a tumultuous time in
her life freshly cleaned from alcohol
and drug addiction forced to live with
her antagonistic mother and having
peculiar and distressing dreams in the
first dream margaret recorded she was
someone else a woman living in a small
hut perhaps a century ago or more it was
plague time she was looking down upon
her daughter bedrin her skin covered in
painful looking red blotches her husband
was already dead that's when another man
enters a healthy man he tells her that
he's found their salvation and then the
dream ended margaret woke up to a gray
dreary day there were clouds on the
horizon the rain was coming it drizzled
for the next few days before getting
more intense as one would expect from an
scp-3300 cycle of course nothing seemed
out of place to margaret life carried on
she continued to stay clean resisting
the offers of her old dealer though her
relationship with her mother remained
frosty the rain started to get worse as
voices on the radio insisted that
conditions would continue to become more
severe over the next few days they tried
their best to maintain normality
margaret invited some friends jared sam
mike and isabelle to come over and play
d d at her place that was when all hal
broke loose while the group role played
there was a furious banging at the door
like whoever was knocking was trying to
bash the door down when margaret's mom
opened the door to investigate the
commotion she saw that an entire family
was standing there a father a mother and
two young children the father
immediately began furiously asking why
all these strangers were in his house
when margaret's mother tried to tell him
that this wasn't his house he became
increasingly agitated and walked
straight into the home margaret's
friends attempted to subdue him but he
threw them off displaying a supernatural
strength margaret's mom ran in with a
golf club and struck the mysterious man
in the chest there was a nasty splat but
he didn't seem to react the golf club
was just embedded in his chest having
broken the skin and sunken in but there
was no blood just dripping water the
father then pulled the golf club out of
his chest and began beating margaret's
mother to death with it all while
repeating my house again and again while
his wife and children watched with broad
sunny smiles in the rain somehow
margaret knew that her mother was beyond
saving and that there was no way of
defeating these things in a physical
confrontation all they could do was run
out to jared's van with the rest of the
group and hightail it to the police
station but when they arrived at the
station the doors were barred and it
appeared empty as the torrential rain
hammered down from above there was
nothing left to do but drive out of town
and try to escape whatever madness was
going on here but that was easier said
than done they drove for what seemed
like hours on end as the rain and the
howling wind persisted jared had been
injured during the fight with the
strange family and his health
deteriorated further as the drive
stretched on they should have left the
town of clearwater a long time ago but
it seemed like they were nowhere it
wasn't long before jared was lying dead
in the back of the van and now there
were only four of them left they kept
driving afraid grieving hungry and tired
and margaret took the opportunity to
sleep it was no time to rest but she was
so exhausted that she had no choice
margaret had a continuation of her
earlier dream the different her the
dream her was laying the plague ridden
body of her daughter in the river but
she wasn't the only one all the villages
of her settlement were placing the
bodies of their dead in the river as the
water washed around them and threw them
the bodies became one with the water and
then they became the water the water was
everything when margaret awoke it was to
the horrifying sounds of bubbling and
boiling that's when she saw that jared's
body was dissolving no not dissolving
evaporating it was bubbling and
convulsing like it was made of water
until the entire thing burst into a
cascade of hot steam after that margaret
and the others left the vehicle and
refused to get back inside nothing was
making sense it was like something out
of a nightmare as they walked the rain
hammered down upon them they couldn't
have been walking for more than a mile
when they crashed into something it was
a sign welcome to clearwater it was like
that the town itself had drawn them back
mike refused to return to the town of
his own free will and began walking in
the other direction moments later he was
walking back towards them in silence
though he never intended to
scp-3300 had distorted his path and
brought him back it was clear that mike
was shaken to the core by the experience
but they had to press on they would head
to the grocery store for food and then
to a sporting goods store where they
could hopefully grab some guns to fight
the violent altered people who'd somehow
appeared with the rain but things didn't
go to plan or what little plan there
even was mike shot himself on the first
night at dirk's sporting goods leaving
only margaret sam and isabel alive
perhaps one of the most terrifying
details of mike's death was the fact he
didn't even bleed instead the gaping
exit wound in the back of his head was
just full of water water was all that
seemed to be left of them sam seemingly
driven to the edge by the sight of
mike's death grabbed a hunting knife to
perform an experiment she'd cut it into
her own skin and was horrified to see
only water dripping out they'd all been
changed and they didn't know why that's
when the survivors noticed something
else there were people standing outside
in the rain hundreds of them not a
single one they could recognize all new
people waiting sam said only one word
outside before walking out of the
hunting goods store and disappearing
into the crowd and the rain never to be
seen again margaret mused that perhaps
in the end she had the right idea to be
taken killed erased or changed would be
inevitable in the final entry in
margaret's diary dreams blend with
reality as her mind finally gives out
from the terror she realizes in her
final moments that there is no way out
there is no escape there is only water
water is eternal the rain
is eternal all will be changed and given
the fact that no trace of margaret was
ever found saved for her diary all her
fears turned out to be right she was
taken and replaced by scp-3300
just as will inevitably happen to all
the current citizens of clearwater the
next time as cp 3300 rolls around it
will be as inevitable and as indifferent
to those it affects as tomorrow's
sunrise you cannot change the rain but
believe us in clearwater montana the
rain can change you now check out
scp-2000 deus ex machina and scp-3001
red reality for more anomalies that'll
make you see the world a little
differently